Speaker 1: Hey, this is this is starting to
now become very, very obvious in terms of
the concern, the panic that Donald Trump has
about the truth, getting out as to what he
was up to and who he was meeting with in the
days leading up to the Trump riots.
We've known now for a little while that Donald
Trump is doing everything he can to get Joe
Biden to assert executive privilege over documents
related to his actions leading up to the Trump
riots.
And so far, Joe Biden has said he's not going
to do that.
We now have learned, thanks to some really
great reporting from CNN Crime and justice
reporter Caitlin Polenz that Donald Trump
is acting desperately to hide his daily schedule
in the days leading up to the Jan. six riot.
Why would he want to do that?
Well, we can infer that if it became known
what he was up to and who he was meeting with,
there would be a lot of overlap with people
that played roles in ginning up and inciting
the Jan. six riots.
Maybe even worse, maybe even worse.
So let's go first to this was this is based
on reporting by Caitlin Pollen's, which will
get to CNN.
Reporter Kaitlan Collins tweeted about this,
saying quote major news overnight.
Per a sworn declaration from the National
Archives, Trump is trying to keep more than
700 pages of files out of the hands of the
Jan. six committee, including 30 pages of
his daily schedule.
Visitor logs and call records for Trump Pence.
Caitlin Polenz reports.
This includes documents from Trump's top aides,
including three handwritten notes from Mark
Meadows proposed talking points for Kayleigh
McEnany, files from Stephen Miller and deputy
counsel Pat Philbin.
The White House Daily Diary and drafts of
remarks regarding the National Archives says
Trump's wants says Trump wants to assert executive
Oh, sorry for remarks regarding Jan. six,
the National Archives says Trump wants to
assert privilege over a handwritten note from
former chief of Staff Mark Meadows files listing
potential or scheduled briefings and telephone
calls concerning the Jan. six certification
and other election issues.
Trump doesn't want it to be known who he was
talking to about how to block the certification
on Jan. six, and we have, you know, some pretty
sensible guesses as to why the report from
CNN's Kaitlan Paul Ince worth reading in full
specifics.
It says specifics about former President Trump's
efforts to keep secret the support from his
White House for overturning his loss of the
2020 election were revealed in late night
court filings detailing more than 700 pages
of handwritten notes, draft documents and
daily logs related to Jan. six.
This is the first time for the first time,
a sworn declaration of what Trump wants to
keep secret.
The records show Trump wants to keep secret,
include handwritten memos from his chief of
staff, call logs of Trump and Pence and White
House visitor records.
Additional court records revealed early Saturday
morning Trump's court case is a crucial and
potentially historic legal fight over the
authority of a former president to protect
his term in office.
The House has subpoena power and the reach
of executive privilege, but it's not only
that it's also an attempt for us not to know
the degree to which Donald Trump was involved
in planning and had foreknowledge of what
ultimately took place on January 6th.
The Trump riots what would his schedule expose?
Well, it's speculation at this point because
we only know the gist of what he wants to
cover up, not the content, because so far
it's not been made public.
But maybe there were too many meetings with
people involved or suspected to be involved
in the Trump riots.
Maybe Trump actually had phone calls with
some of the people that organized and carried
out violence.
We just don't know, and I'm conceding that
this is speculation, but this is not the behavior
of an innocent person.
Now, hold on a second.
Hold on a second.
I'm not saying Trump doesn't deserve due process,
I'm not saying anything about that.
People are innocent until proven guilty in
a court of law, and it doesn't mean that Trump
is guilty, so everybody relax.
I know that the there's a contingent where
every time I say this is not the behavior
of an innocent person, someone writes and
says David.
That ignores due process.
People aren't guilty in the U.S. until proven
innocent.
This isn't a court of law.
This is my show, and it is my opinion colloquially
that this is not the behavior of an innocent
person.
That doesn't mean he's guilty of anything
in a in a criminal trial.
It's not what I'm saying.
He's not even been charged.
The one other thought about this, Trump seems
to sort of be telling the January 6th Committee
exactly where to look for the most relevant
evidence about his behavior by making it clear
what it is he doesn't want revealed blasting.
All of this relates to the release of these
these documents to the January 6th Committee.
If they are released to the Jan. six committee,
there is no guarantee that they will actually
be made public to us, they may leak, of course,
that that that's always a risk.
But this is not about making these documents
public.
This is about making them available to the
Jan. six committee.
What do you believe is in Trump's schedule
and call logs that he wants to cover up?
Let me know.
We'll have more on this on our Instagram,
which you can find at David Pakman show